en plena temporada de vacaciones el
aeropuerto de la capital argentina se
llena de habitantes de la calle
afectados por la crisis económica del
país en busca de un refugio hay
muchísima gente entraron más ahora a la
noche cuando si vienen van a ver está
relleno
esto es poco la comparación de la noche
porque hace frío nos quedamos acá porque
hace frío
Roxana Silva se vio obligada a convertir
el aeropuerto en su hogar Desde hace dos
años afectada por la pobreza que golpea
casi al 40% de la población
si yo pago el alquiler no como
si
pagó la comida estoy en la calle Los
Altos precios son una realidad que
comparten todos los argentinos en
febrero la inflación anual superó los
tres dígitos y se ubicó en
102,5%, una de las cifras más altas en
el mundo el aeropuerto convertido en
Refugio no oficial es algo inusual para
Los viajeros gente que vive acá y que
vive acá muchos años y eso me sobra
muchísimo no porque primera vez que veo
que en un aeropuerto viva gente
indigente no la situación del país
también obliga a otros a partir me voy a
Francia tengo trabajo allá ya me
considero un trabajo
así que pues me voy para allá Porque es
difícil la situación acá para mí la
situación es difícil mi sueldo no no me
alcanza para alquilar o sea por más que
me aumente Los sueldos la inflación es
muy alta en Argentina 18,6 millones de
personas no pueden cubrir sus
necesidades alimentarias básicas una
cifra que no disminuye pese a los
esfuerzos oficiales por estabilizar la
golpeada economía Mientras tanto cada
día llegan más personas a este
particular refugio